el mout commandera le king dernière
s'est il encore fertilise maxi coq ou
ketchup auto interview voici lunettes
noires pour nuits blanches les messieurs
qui ne seraient rossum les aucune autre
j'étais trop
cette maman
nous sommes en bons
d losio
avec
est ce que tu dis
le maintien frazer
je ne regarde pas
ses dépens
que ce soit fait je bois je sais pas
soir c'est papa
je n'ai jamais été question
les bras c'est fini non
tu aideras vous à venir
[Musique]
un temps et le jour 2
quant à ces ans
temps des
commandes y avoir une taille escompté
murray et enfants
dans une longue histoire
bah les cabarets qui je veux parler
à
les îles en mer egée
contre avec les cinémas
j'étais avec un écart
machaie damas riyad
l'étranger
et à terme en france un des forêts je ne
dis rien à détruire les derniers fruits
ce matin
est ce qu'on a
oh
les âmes et après je vais voir
ce
mais elle avait par contre
une restauration
bien georges abbou
[Musique]
mais vraiment
peut-être je suis plus riches
angoissé est-ce que tu n'es pas
trop cher de taussat
je veux pas répondre
vous avez cru
mais un terrain
kuta aussi
là
alors
depuis
lama
31% remedial locquénolé scorn c'est dit
je sais pas
de
[Musique]
démarrer c'est vrai maintenant toujours
du livre
j'ai pas les passes et
je sais
regardez à droite à gauche
[Musique]
je pars je veux pas parler
et
que je passais
square mais tu crois je dirais trouverai
quelqu'un lors louis alors bonjour
je crois assez savoureux
-
mais pourquoi c elle se
[Musique]
voit pas
c'est tellement
après brigitte bardot
d12
me regarde moi
mais il
c'est
je veux dire ici le basque
adra voilà d'or
quelque chose déjà
il
préférait
ouais
ils n'ont pas
la même année
[Musique]
donnez moi mais comment
passé
oh
c'était
à refaire j'ai rajouté quentin
[Musique]
moi j'ai courage et plus nombreux que le
jeune
jusque mois à 6 ans
des plus
pas mal
16 ans il produisait
un trader
le de qualité les manettes et
il a plu
respect
tout le monde est très très très
sur votre sol
dcm
à l'époque ces systèmes
romantique avec un regard c'était un
régal
[Applaudissements]
et bien voilà
des commandes
on a voulu
[Musique]
tous les ados
tout excès jarrell
m mais posez n'ont jamais les projets
des jeux
cela m'a
qu'est-ce qu'elle rêverait
des vosges et à
je suis pas avec vous
que le quart
roger
balan de chaunac et les corrections de
ne rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux